can we talk about the big bang a little
bit
sure yeah yeah what uh so like
the entirety of it the universe
yeah it was very small right but it was
not a point
it was not okay because if we live in
what's called a closed universe now
a sphere or the three-dimensional
version of that would be a hypersphere
you know then regardless of how far back
in time
you go it was always that topological
shape
you can't turn a point suddenly into a
shell okay it always had to be a shell
so when when people say well the
universe started out as a point
that's being kind of flippant kind of
glib it didn't really it just started
out
at a very high density and we don't know
actually whether it was finite or
infinite i think
personally that it was finite at the
time but it expanded very very quickly
indeed if it exponentiated and continued
in some places to exponentiate then it
could in fact be
infinite right now and most cosmologists
think that it is infinite
yes sorry what uh infinite which
dimension mass
emphasizes space infinite in space and
by that i mean that if you were trying
to
use light to measure its size you'd
you'd never
be able to measure its size because it
would always be bigger than the distance
light can travel
that's what you get in a universe that's
accelerating in its expansion
okay but you know if a thing was a
hypersphere
it's very small not a point yeah how can
that thing be
infinite well it expands exponentially
that's what the inflation theory is all
about
indeed at your home institution alan
guth is one of the originators
of the whole inflationary universe idea
along with andre linde
at stanford university here in the bay
area and others lexi
starabinsky and others had similar sorts
of ideas but
in an exponentially expanding universe
if you actually try to make this
measurement
you send light out to try to see it
curve back around and
hit you in the back of the head it's an
exponentially expanding universe
the amount of space remaining to be
traversed
is always a bigger and bigger quantity
so you'll never get there from here
you'll never
you'll never reach the back of your head
so observationally or operationally it
can be thought of as being influenced
that's one of the best definitions of
infinity by the way what's that
that's one of the best sort of uh
physical manifestations of infinity okay
yeah because you have to
ask how would you actually measure it
now i sometimes say to my cosmology
theoretical friends well if i took
if i were god and i were outside this
whole thing and i took a godlike slice
in time wouldn't it be finite no matter
how big it is and
they object and they say alex you you
can't be
outside and take a godlike slice of time
you know
because there's nothing outside well i'm
not you know
or also you know what slice of time
you're taking depends
on your motion and that's true even in
special relativity that
slices of time get tilted in a sense if
you're
moving quickly the axis x and t
actually become tilted not not
perpendicular to one another
um and you know you can look at brian
green's books and lectures and other
things where
he he imagines taking a loaf loaf of
bread
and slicing it in units of time as you
progress forward
but then if you're zipping along
relative to that
loaf of bread the slices of thyme
actually become
tilted and so it's not even clear what
slices of time mean
but i i'm an observational astronomer i
know which end of the telescope to look
through and the way i understand the
infinity is as i just told you that
operationally or observationally there
no there'd be no way of seeing that it's
a finite
universe of measuring a finite universe
and so in that sense
it's it's infinite even if it started
out
as a finite little dot
not a dot i'm sorry a finite little
hypersphere
you